d / - we have an attacking genius with
us as Maurice Ashley has garry kasparov
you said it right alejandro truly an
attacking genius and he started coming
in here by showing me one of his vintage
lines that we will show you in a moment
first of all Gary welcome back to the
show we know you're back in zagreb for
the young stars program yeah it's so
traditional program in the United States
gets purchased Foundation has been
running this program for over the decade
and we have already with a generation of
young rising stars in the US and it's
our first international session so it's
the it's them six Europeans here so one
girl five boys and we hope it will
become traditional as well so it's it's
it's an attempt to actually spread this
the our experience and the traditions of
Soviet chess school that we incorporated
in the United States to the rest of the
world you said Europeans not
specifically not just Croatians we saw
one youngster Robert Krang go from from
other countries gracious actually
Croatian yeah but unfortunately doesn't
have young stars of that caliber so we
have kid from Denmark Poland Romania
France
Selenia and and the girl from she lives
in Russia but she represents Kazakhstan
so let's see that's that's our
collection here of $66.00 truly
internationally international yes so
it's that's and again that was an idea
that just you know to make sure that as
far as foundation will operate you know
just in all continents and I'm quite
proud that now we can extend our
programs from this just from offering
help for schools to actually offering
assistance to young stars now we see
Croatia being a host to this kind of
that event and this events earlier we
had the chief of staff of the Prime
Minister on and he was extremely excited
exuberant about the fact that chest was
at this level here in Croatia when I got
my Croatian passport five years ago so I
promise to make Croatian the center of
chess activities in the region and I
have to say that I don't expect this
kind of reaction exuberant reaction from
Croatian public and Croatian officials
about Grantchester event and now they
are they're talking about I can making
it a traditional event which is yeah
it's challenging because next year will
be very crowded here with candidates
World Championship Olympia so we will
have most likely we have a shorter
version of branches - simply because we
cannot you know put you know all the
events you know inside this packed
calendar but naturally in 2021 will be
seriously considering coming back to the
Zagreb because they they really want
this event to to become sort of a crown
jewel of our activities purchased
Foundation activities in Croatia and in
the whole region I gotta say it's been a
beautiful city and a wonderful reception
so far let's get to the games you are
you really had your eye on this game
Magnus and you came in with one of these
crazy wild variations that I love to see
though that's aged for you know that
because it seems to me that this age for
you you said a couple of days ago that
just down
nobody is just you know is surprised to
see aged for you know it moved six or
seven so it's very early stage and and
Magnus play chess that is I would say
typical for him so it's more like you
know tall Kasparov but not not Magnus
but I was you know quite pleased to see
to see him you know having such an
attacking aggressive attitude but you
know I could feel what he missed
something so that's that's what when I
looked at the position when momma Dee up
to Cundieff or so I wasn't just on my
just my tablet so I just said let's say
okay this is natural one is just you
know this could be sheep on c4 of course
yes yeah but you know I it's the it's 27
so this is the Queen c7 so it's I didn't
see Queen b3 so that's because my my
it's again the way I might work so this
I wanted to go over there killa day and
I instantly I want to play Queen g4 so
Quinn g4 and it's this is because the
idea is that now if black takes on c4
then is this already
Ruka check check miss appreciate Queen
h4 now Queens three Bishop d2 doesn't
help and King g7 were actually pushy
five
so I love what unfortunately
unfortunately as you just pointed out
that is a fact 97 it's just you know the
attackee day comes to an end and it's
it's a draw
yeah yeah but stick to the line but
smelled it but actually this it's it's
it's it's it's not typical for magnums
because you know it's everything depends
on one move and Magnus is very good in
just in there and just in squeezing his
opponent says this and now I I don't
know I don't know how comfortable he's
at this very point I think it's where we
are here is now but it's again the way
it's he plays it's just it's it's not
his game so that's why I yeah anything I
have in this game so this is considering
you know the way they play a lot of you
know the fighting spirit but very often
in our mistakes yes that's the I mean
anything can happen I mean it's in this
game anything of the results can can can
can be fixed
you said something intriguing though
Magnus we all know he's got that style
that the boa constrictor he's come he's
gonna last forever and beat you but
lately he's been crushing people with
mating attacks especially with black
what is what's going on the evolution of
his father is he is he starting to lean
as you see here he played hh4 this one
to lean more to the aggressive style
it's look first of all you know that's
it's it's more and more difficult to
actually get you know promising
positions without taking risk so Magnus
knows it and look you know it's I wasn't
this is in this high atmosphere 25 years
ago when you are not just in a hundred
points ahead of ahead of anybody else so
and it's your average rating is 100 plus
points the Irish to me I'm a point below
then yours you have to take risk so
that's why I you know II and and I think
he just he you know it's it's this sort
of a conflict between his you know
natural style but also he is a fighting
spirit he wants to win and he knows he
has to take risk
and again I'm grateful I mean as I think
we also the great for him that instead
of just trying to play four plus two
plus three yesterday he's
fighting in every game so I think he
spends more time at the chairs more than
any other player and that's phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal and I'd i think
that's see that whatever happens in this
game so i mean i'm really happy that you
know we could see world champion is
taking this risk and just and ready to
you know just to to play this very
aggressive chess because it's it's just
not important for him just to win but
it's important for public to see that
yeah classical chess is not that it's
all about the attitude
if you willing to take you know your
chances and and and risk so anything in
happen what do you talk about nepal
Miyaichi in hit the stages right now he
went off to a flying start at three
points but his play has been a little
bit tricky no that's the the lady lock
you know could have strange preferences
so i mean if you look at the quality of
the games i know there's nothing to be
proud of but at the end of the day who
cares you know this is he has plus three
and today it was luck again I mean it
said move ten if it was really worse and
at one point he was just sliding down so
downhill and I think you correctly could
deliver but he failed so well see so
it's this game with net poise you know
he can win many games but he can start
losing games that's in we know that's
this is that's that's his nature but
again that's good because it makes the
whole event unpredictable so it's the we
are just you know we we are in them in
the middle of the event that could end
up with any results so we just yeah I
think Magnus is still a favorites there
again we'll see what happens this game
but it's the factors that nepo is that
this is taking a leap Weezy notes this
was plus three of the four rounds it's
just and and the fact that Magnus Magnus
somehow showed I think this the his
vulnerability when I blow vision that's
that's that's I know I know what's
happening I was just I again I was there
many times
great game talk about our planes machine
and then he relaxed he already had okay
full point you know just okay I won the
game and Vichy give him credit he found
that's the only this is unique study
like draw so let's just get world
champion and world champion even actual
temple so I think I think we'd enjoy it
again so this is just it's it's it's I
will sets masterpiece but it just showed
that two great players they fought to
the very last
well you're used to seeing that happen
with the great greatest of the greats
one last question on the rivalry between
Fabi and Magnus we saw them play a
terrific game as well trying to the very
end you had a rival back in the day it's
not quite there yet
you had 170 games against Karpov what do
you think about this rivalry number one
and number two is it when you're gonna
see last for another 5-10 years look I
can tell you Magnus will be there so now
it's up to Fabi to make sure he will be
around so I I think that you know that
Fadi probably was wounded when he
couldn't deliver the decisive blow
against the Palacios so it was a very
good game he's outplayed him completely
so she's interesting that he played the
opening that he tried many times against
madness was white and he played was
black but again something that was wrong
you know with the position this not
evaluation Emily she was beautiful black
but psychological I mean Fabian and he
prefers you know just to have very sort
of clear cuts you know this is swine and
and there it was there was it was murky
and he I mean he just I still don't
understand why he didn't take on d5 I
mean this is it is so I mean it's you
don't have to calculate alliances just
there were other wins but it's who you
take on d5 Queen txt five and then he
played them rook c8 and Justin it's a
fourth and game and two its technical
win for black so I thought she would do
this even without thinking you are in
time trouble
grab the palm you grab the porn you
protect your own porn and you securely
no yes you your your pawn structure and
its technical win maybe nervous maybe
just in our Fabi
Bobby wants to compete with Magnus and
it just you know is still missing
something so but if you look at other
players having hobbies the only one who
can really give Magnus run for his money
you know we just I just have to say one
thing the passion you still have for the
game you're so excited to see this
high-level chess it looks like you're
just one of Jessa's biggest fans still
no cups absolutely so that's the passion
that will never go away so SSI and
anytime I see these games like this one
yeah it's just it's it's it's something
it's tickling exactly
I'm gonna get in that ring thanks so
much for joining us Gary we know you got
a lot of work next next building we have
this kids and then afterwards kids so
our program so I'll join you any time
world champion Garrick is part of always
a treat to interview thank you very
thank you Gary